[Music]
it's hard to put aside two thoughts when
thinking about Africa the first is the
thing that Africa is a continent forever
sentence to poverty illness starvation
and tragedy and a loss of tragedy so the
Africa is often thought of as a somewhat
compact territory when everything is
connected
so westernized Africa can look more like
a country than a continent with many
failing to realize the colossal size of
this continent Africa is as big as
Europe the US India China and Argentina
combined so now you can imagine the
diversity that this huge territory must
contain the announcement centers the
economists referred to Africa and the
continent without us as can often happen
things that rapidly changed in Africa
since the start of the 21st century
Africa has experienced a significant
boost especially in the poorest
countries on the continent with the
exception of South Africa the countries
of sub-saharan Africa achieved annual
growth rates of 6.2 percent by
comparison that is twice the growth rate
of countries in Latin America during the
same time period in 2015
five of the ten economies that grew the
most in the world we're in Africa these
are the Ivory Coast Ethiopia Tanzania
Rwanda and the Democratic Republic of
Congo the growth rate of these countries
exceeded seven percent the Democratic
Republic of Congo is being ranked among
the top ten countries for reforms in the
world for example in 2014 there are
already nearly 7,000 enterprises that
have been created although the growth
figures were a bit smaller the situation
remains similar in the year 2016 all of
this growth has led to some really
significant social consequences so let's
have a look at some of these for one
life expectancy has increased
significantly over the last eight years
and child mortality figures and those
dying from starvation has been cut in
half the summer extreme poverty used to
affect 58% of the population in 1999 and
now it has decreased to just 35% it is
still true that more than 420 million
people are still suffering from extreme
poverty in Africa which is tragic but
fortunately the future is looking
brighter than ever another thing is also
certain Africa is going to have a major
global role in the coming decades and
it's middle-class or consumer class is
the fastest growing in the world the
fact is Africa is no longer emerging it
is here now Africa is being urbanized
quickly which allows for both the
provision of public services and also
economies of scale in the near future
we are going to find many of the world's
biggest cities are on this continent
and you know Lagos Nigeria your Acura
might become the new Shanghai in just a
few short decade for example the tallest
skyscraper in Africa the hack towers
currently being built in Nairobi in
Accra the capital city of Ghana six
walls have been built in only six years
and while that might not seem like a lot
when you consider that there was only
one mall in the entire city before those
six new ones were built it seems like a
little bit more foreign investments has
also grown strongly in the last few
years and half of these investments
operate in areas that have nothing to do
with Africa's natural resources this is
important because many of the countries
in Africa are trying to develop
industries outside of raw materials so
they are depending less on these natural
resources these economies are known as
the African lions the apps become lions
these African lions include Kenya Uganda
Tanzania and Mozambique and Zambia these
are the countries in Africa that are
developing the fastest now we're going
to discuss each of them in detail in
upcoming videos but today we're just
going to focus on three of them one this
is a small country with a population of
only 12 million people and it doesn't
have any coastline it is still a poor
country but it is registered and almost
9 percent annual growth since the year
2001 and importantly this country has no
oil or other important natural resources
so the big question is well how do they
do it
this has actually been mostly down to
supporting business creation this is why
Rwanda is the second easiest country to
do business in in sub-saharan Africa
according to the World Bank doing
business report so the question you
might be asking is this is a coincidence
and we have visual politics we really
don't think so we are now for example
looking at the secondary cities the
cities if they were organized if they
were visited and you put everything
that's needed and he's a little
connected the portable growth now thanks
to all of this nearly all children have
primary education and the 98 percent of
its people already have access to health
care as a consequence child mortality
has been reduced by 60 percent and AIDS
and malaria have also seen significant
reductions further Rwanda spreadin Paul
Kagame claims to be a disciple of Lee
Kuan Yew the legendary leader of
Singapore here we're going to be
discussing
an upcoming episode so don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already so you
were getting notified about that and
also won't miss out on any of our other
videos
Ethiopia this is a much larger country
with a population of nearly 100 million
people in Ethiopia around 20 million
people still have nutritional problems
and that is not the only problem they
have the government's also become more
authoritarian recently however things
are changing faster than today
Ethiopia's capital addis ababa is always
pursuing significant construction
project in fact about a year ago at a
salad bar opens the first modern tram
system in all of sub-saharan Africa and
to be honest they deserve it if the Opia
is a country which has grown
significantly in the last 10 years its
economy is multiplied by a factor of 5
in this period and its GDP has grown by
over 10 percent every year
tomah's very colorful run run run run
run run in Busan so now you might be
asking well how did they do it well they
were simply trying to be more attractive
to investors it's in their neighboring
country in doing so the country has
established two main priorities one
achieved stable macroeconomics and to
establish attractive taxation for
example import of technological
equipment such as machinery does not
have any import charge further companies
don't have any tags in their first 5
years which is pretty nice but planner
so we couldn't do this video without
mentioning Botswana the country which
recently celebrated in 2016 the 50th
anniversary of its independence what
SWANA has been the greatest economic
success story in all of Africa in fact
it is even one of the most successful
worldwide at the time of Botswana
independence in the year 1966 it was one
of the poorest countries on the planet
on top of that the country has suffered
severe droughts and has suffered from
the second largest AIDS epidemic in the
world in spite of all these obstacles
the country has experienced development
so significant that its GDP in
purchasing power pariah tea is
equivalent to countries such as Colombia
Brazil or Thailand this is obviously
considering the different levels of
prices among these countries
[Music]
here the key to success can be found in
these strengths of its national
institutions their healthy public
finances and above all the country's
legal certainty in fact in the last CPI
corruption perception index for SWANA
was ranked since 31st position this is a
better position than countries like
Spain Israel or Taiwan rule of law
regulatory reform good governance those
things matter even more because people
should be able to start a business and
ship their goods without having to pay a
bribe or hire somebody's cousin but now
how about some more surprising facts
about Africa you should know that this
continent is already home to 400
companies with a turnover of more than a
billion dollars a year so it really does
seem that the end of Africa being a
totally poor continent is coming to an
end furthermore in Africa we can also
find Nollywood the second largest film
industry in terms of films produced in
the world only two thousand five hundred
films less than Bollywood so that in
Nigeria loans the film industry employs
around a million workers am I and now
for just one final surprise Africa is
the world leader in online banking and
mobile phone payments yes you probably
weren't expecting that but it is
absolutely true today many farmers share
information through SMS and in the
strengths of Rwanda it is popular to use
safemotos which is like a Rwandan
version of either except this is more
different instead of using cars they use
motorcycles because there are very few
cars available so the thing about Africa
is that it is changing incredibly fast
but the truth is that there are still
many challenges and difficulties that
the continent is going to face ahead for
example consolidating the rule of law
reducing poverty and improving their
infrastructure and of course they need
to put an end once and for all to all
those terrible dictatorships in
countries like Angola Eritrea or
Equatorial Guinea however everything
does seem to indicate that the future
for Africa is brighter than it has ever
been so I hope you found that video
interesting and we would love to know
what you think do you think that Africa
is going to become a major player in the
coming decades student let us know in
the comments below we love to read them
and know what you guys think also do
click the like button below this video
if you enjoyed it and don't forget to
subscribe to brand new videos every
Monday and
research day and I'll see you in the
next one
[Applause]
[Music]